patrick ferrasse bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors tout juste un
an après le début du conflit du tigre et
en ethiopie l'eau est nulle conclu dans
un rapport de possibles crimes de guerre
de crimes contre l'humanité commis par
toutes les parties du conflit et dénonce
une brutalité extrême qu'est ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui précisément de la
situation sur place
la situation sur place si l'on peut dire
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est comme le
reportage de l'annoncé il ya une reprise
militaire des tigres et 1 depuis le mois
de juin 2021 et les militaires tigre r
aujourd'hui font reculer l'armée
éthiopienne on a vu que comme le fait
d'essayer de villes stratégiques sont
tombées aux mains des rebelles puis ce
qu'on appelle rebelles aujourd'hui des
tigres est depuis ce week-end dire
qu'ils sont avancés de 150 kilomètres à
l'intérieur des terres amara et ils ont
fait 300 km depuis la capitale mais quel
est donc oui 1 4 mois ils ont pris
beaucoup d'accent sur le terrain est
davantage sur le terrain tant que la
situation sur le terrain pour l'instant
elle est plutôt à l'avantagé des tigres
et l'armée sur le front est remettez
national fédéral recul si on peut dire
et c'est un très mauvais signe si l'on
peut dire pour le premier ministre
actuellement malgré
l'état d'urgence qu'il a décrétée il ya
deux jours comment expliquer que l'armée
éthiopienne c'est pourtant l'une des
armées les plus opérationnels l'afrique
subsaharienne n'arrive pas à maîtriser
cette offensive des rebelles
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont mieux
commandes et ils sont stratégiquement
parlant et tactiquement parlant beaucoup
plus fort que l'armée fédérale
aujourd'hui ne faut ne faut pas oublier
que quand tu as bien med a lancé son
offensive au début du mois de novembre
il a éjecté la totalité des tigres et de
tous les postes de commandement et de
toutes les unités et touquet terre qu'il
ya eu à peu près 20 à 25 mille personnes
qui ont été mis sur le côté emprisonnés
dans des camps et que 7,7 ce manque à
gagner si l'on peut dire des forces
éthiopiennes se paye aujourd'hui à la
halle même temps vous avez une
population qui est extrêmement motivé
vous avez rappelé avec les rapports
d'amnesty international et nations unies
ce qui s'est passé au tigre aille donc
la population est complètement derrière
le type élèves aujourd'hui est prête à
n'importe quoi pour que habib ahmed
tombe l'objectif numéro 1 des tigres est
aujourd'hui c'est de faire tomber à bien
m comment expliquer justement mais
finalement ce retournement de situation
puisque l'élite y elle avait soutenu à
l'arrivée au pouvoir de habib ahmed il y
a à l'époque elle n'avait pas porté
forcément soutenu si vous laissez
surtout d'alliance oromo amara qui a
battu les tigres et en 2018 et qui a
donc mis sur la touche des tigres est un
et donc petit à petit les tigres un sont
retirés du jeu forcé est obligé par
cette nouvelle alliance au homard a donc
il n'y a pas eu forcément on se l'est de
davantage de pousser vers a bien raide
tout le monde cpc a pensé que c'était un
jeune un jeune quadra qui allait prendre
le pouvoir et donné quelques nouvelles
directions économique et politique mais
bon ça c'est pas du tout passé ainsi
mais les tigres n ont jamais appuyé à
bien jouer c'est les oromos les amharas
dans une alliance communes qui ont forcé
les tigres et un à se retirer du jeu
politique
et petit à petit à se retirer dans leur
région ce qui a mené ce que votre
reportage 10 et des élections organisées
par les tigres est un qui n'a pas plu au
gouvernement fédéral et donc apporter ce
moment là a bien mais natixis que la
peine lors info ce matin les chutes les
opérations de rétablissement de l'ordre
en région tigré et c'est parti de là
aujourd'hui les formes de vie réelle
affirme que la prise de la capitale
addis abeba n'est qu'une question de
mois si ce n'est de deux semaines alors
est-ce qu'on peut envisager une défaite
militaire du gouvernement ben ali ahmed
marzouki sur le front est pour l'instant
au niveau de la région de comme auch a
été sciée c'est une défaite pour
l'instant militaire je voulais qu'ils se
sont avancés depuis 300 km depuis mais
quel est donc en 4 mois et donc ils font
peur s'ils voulaient à cette prise de
l'impossible de la capitale sur le front
ouest les combats continuent mais
l'importance stratégique aujourd'hui sur
le front est et on peut très bien
envisager cadiz avait pas tombe demain
la partie mont l'armée recul comme elle
le fait aujourd'hui il va rester des
poches de résistance et donc les tigres
et avons monté jusqu'à 10 abeba
l'objectif principal de des tigres et là
ils ont annoncé écrit depuis octobre
2020 c'est la chute de ben yahmed ce
n'est pas récupéré des provinces et les
engloutir sur l'argentique c'est
simplement éjecté le premier ministre de
son poste soit donc un petit moment où
c'est leur objectif principal ils vont
le tenir s'il n'est pas bien sûr s'il
n'y a pas de retournement de situation
mais dans tous les cas de figure qui
vont au monde et tranquillement si l'on
peut dire méthodiquement comme ils le
font depuis quatre mois si vous regardez
bien la tacc toutes les attaques ils ont
mené aujourd'hui et sont méthodiques et
sont stratégiques et petit à petit ils
avancent leurs pions donc il est évident
que si les victoires continue ils vont
aller jusqu'à 10 abeba et faire en sorte
que le premier ministre démissionne ou
parte alors le premier ministre ahmed
qui lui bénéficié d'un crédit plutôt
favorables en europe aux états unis
grâce à ses efforts de réconciliation
mené avec l'erythrée ça lui valut
d'ailleurs le prix nobel de la paix en
2019 quelle est la position aujourd'hui
de la communauté internationale
le comité national elle a commencé à
revoir ses positions depuis très
longtemps si vous êtes sous l'impulsion
que des américains des nations-unies
avec les rapports prévus l'union
européenne aussi a suspendu ses
paiements la france était très longue à
réagir à l'appui de sept à huit mois
pour réagir ce qui était un petit peu
faible polychrome à 6 actifs comme nom
de l'avant mais aujourd'hui la
communauté internationale est sur le qui
vive et c'est très bien aperçu que la
firme n est pas l'homme providentiel
reconnu par tout le monde elle va donc
laisser la situation
perdurer malheureusement parce que les
deux hommes les deux protagonistes
conquérant que les cobayes ils ne
s'arrêteront pas s'il ya bien mais ne
démissionne pas où ce n'est pas perdant
aussi des brics yonne pour le tpf n'est
pas perdant sur les tombes ne
s'arrêteront pas quelles que soient les
rapports que vous pourrez écrire les
sanctions qui seront prises par
l'extérieur de la comédie internationale
ce conflit aujourd'hui il est uniquement
internat à l'ethiopie où il pourrait
devenir régional
non il est il il n'est déjà pas du tout
interne puisque l'erythrée s'en est mêlé
si on peut dire mais ça c'est parce que
habib ahmed l'a voulu dans l'accord de
paix de 2018 y avait une alliance
potentielle de des erythréens et
éthiopiens pour vient simplement
contourné le tiraille en prenant le
tigre est par le nord avec les
erythréens et par le sud avec l'armée
fédérale à bien mettre pensée résoudre
le problème s'est rapidement se s'est
pas passé de la même façon si on peut
dire oui c'est un conflit qui reste
quand même néanmoins limité
à ce qu'on a pour rappel la sphère
ethiopie erythrée mais bon pas plus loin
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui des grosses
inquiétudes sur le plan humanitaire
oui devant l'inquiétude parce que s'ils
voulaient non seulement la région du
tigre haye est touché sur le plan
humanitaire mais la région amara
aujourd'hui qui est fortement prise à
partie par les tigres et
les
wallons position peut lire et le fait de
bloquer l'accès combo chad est ce qui
fait que vous bloquer l'accès logistique
djibouti est loin et je vous rappelle
que dix soldats et un pays enclavé elle
a besoin de ce port de tyr outil si vous
coupez un axe logistique c'est un
extrêmement important cet objet de
contourner ce qui est possible mais avec
des délais si on les suit on dire qu'ils
vont se rallonger et vous savez que les
aides humanitaires ont du mal à arriver
horizon tigres il donc à régir o'mara
comme en région afar ce sera encore pire
donc aujourd'hui je confie cette enlisé
si l'on peut dire mais il est même allé
il est même allé jusqu'à donner deux
régions du sud sont la région a marre à
la région afar merci beaucoup patrick
firas pour votre éclairage ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
docteur en géopolitique spécialiste de
l'ethiopie
[Musique]